Треба рухатися швидко. Ми прямуємо на передові позиції. Росіяни дуже близько звідси.
Військові кажуть, що це одна з або найперша позиція на цій ділянці лінії фронту.
Звідси до позицій, де знаходяться російські вороги, приблизно 150 метрів.
Ці позиції знаходяться південніше Бахмута. Але через певні природні перешкоди
ворогу дуже важко вести тут будь-який наступ.
Натомість збройні сутички та артобстріли тут постійно. Дістати може будь-яка зброя.
Це росіяни стріляють у відповідь.
Відкриває вогонь для того, щоб дізнатися, скільки нас тут, де ми знаходимося.
Солдат за кулеметом зізнається, що з кожним днем відчуває все більший тиск.
Він каже, що ворог їх випробовує, до чогось готується.
Так, це відчувається: з кожним днем все гірше і гірше.
І, ймовірно, ситуація буде загострюватися найближчим часом.
Ви бачите, що весна зараз досить суха. Тому дуже зручно робити будь-які наступальні дії для всіх.
Тому, ймовірно, ситуація загостриться в найближчі дні чи тижні.
І справа в тому, хто і де буде їх проводити. Весь цей час вони намагаються
форсувати цей напрямок, щоб "продати" російському народу взагалі якусь перемогу.
Тож вони, ймовірно, будуть тиснути у найближчі дні.
Снайпери і мінометники становлять тут постійну загрозу.
Тут нахиляйтеся. Он ворожі позиції, тільки обачно дивіться.
Пересуватися будь-куди - небезпечно. У наступному бліндажі зустрічаємо
чоловіка з позивним "Таксист". Раніше він працював на Алясці в США.
Та з початком повномасштабної війни пішов до армії і не бачив свою родину місяцями.
Вчора його синові виповнилося 6 років.
Ми запитали у нього, як він справляється тут, на передовій.
Страшно, страшно… І ти думаєш про десятки тисяч загиблих…
Цих хлопців, які… увечері з тобою курили цигарку…
І за кілька годин - їх немає. Думаєш, щодня думаєш.
Незважаючи на все це, військові тут будуть продовжувати битися.
Бахмут - який недалеко звідси - повинен вистояти, кажуть військові.
Від самого Бахмута йде дві стратегічно важливі дороги, з яких противник
може розвинути напрямки на будь-якій ділянці фронту.
Плюс у них там зосереджене доволі велике угруповання військ.
Якщо прорвуть нашу лінію оборони - вони зможуть розвинути далі вглиб нашого країни.
І для обох сторін Бахмут залишається потужним символом.
Ворог гине, а наш моральний дух високий. Якщо вони настільки дурні,
щоб "продати" перемогу, захопивши Бахмут… На початку війни вони за три дні
намагалися захопити Київ, Харків. Але Київ стоїть, Харків стоїть.
А тепер намагаються "продати" Бахмут.
Звідси можна зрозуміти, як насправді виглядає друга армія світу.
Проте критики стверджують, що Бахмут більше не вартий тієї ціни,
яку Україна платить життями. Військові ж вважають по-іншому.
Неважливо, чи то росіяни, чи хтось інший, але вони прийшли на нашу землю.
Це ворог, це окупант, його треба знищити, його треба вигнати звідси.
Яку ціну платять українці - добре видно у цьому стабілізаційному пункті.
Ми не можемо сказати, де ми знаходимося. Але бої тут дуже близько.
Ця занедбана будівля - нині польовий шпиталь.
Тут лікарі працюють цілодобово, щоб рятувати життя. Їхнє розташування
в небезпечній зоні є вирішальним. Поранених привозять сюди прямо з передової
і стабілізують, щоб вони могли пережити дорогу до госпіталя.
Цей чоловік отримав осколкове поранення живота.
Хірург Дмитро зі своєю командою негайно береться за нього.
Через пів години його вдається стабілізувати для подальшого переміщення.
Щодня бригади виконують тут до 80 операцій.
Останні випадки поранень - це 90% осколкових поранень від артилерії.
У цьому місці, в цьому стабілізаційному пункті ми також маємо багато кульових поранень,
тому що війна ведеться в місті і наш ворог використовує тісний контакт
з нашими солдатами, тому в нас більше випадків з кульовими пораненнями.
Здебільшого це осколкові ураження. Найчастіше це кінцівки,
бо вони у нас найменш захищені. Набагато рідше голова.
Це десь відсотків 10-15 від загальної кількості.
Велика кількість акубаротравм, тобто це (травми) внаслідок дії вибухової хвилі.
Може не бути зовнішніх пошкоджень тіла, але воно може викликати
і струси головного мозку, і забої головного мозку.
В найкращому випадку це може бути розрив барабанної перетинки.
Дмитро до повномасштабної війни керував компанією з клінічних випробувань.
Але зараз він вирішив бути тут, у кімнаті без вікон, де чути запах поранень
і звуки війни. Але вони змінюють ситуацію, каже він.
Ми стаємо більш професійними, і кожен з персоналу знає, що йому чи їй робити
в цьому випадку. Ми створюємо деякі власні протоколи для допомоги.
У медиків, як і у військових, тут немає поняття робочого дня.
Все зливається у дні, тижні і місяці.
Медична рота - це не такий вже величезний підрозділ, щоб хтось міг собі дозволити
запланувати: завтра я буду спати. У нас такого немає.
У нас всі працюють майже цілодобово. 24 на 7.
Сьогодні (я спав) півтори години, вчора напевно години 4.
Чим ефективніше і вправніше ми працюємо на нашому етапі,
тим більше бійців лишаються з мінімальними для себе втратами,
тим більше бійців можуть повернутися.
Повернутися не тільки до лав бойових підрозділів,
повернутися до цивільного життя абсолютно нормальними і здоровими.
За годину їзди від окопів - станція Краматорськ.
Саме тут військові прощаються з різними, які приїхали їх побачити.
Дружини та дівчата їдуть в безпечне місце, а чоловіки повертаються на лінію фронту.
Ціна за Бахмут справді висока, але Україна готова платити.